Alors que la quasi totalité des œuvres sur le sujet nous le déconseillent,
faut-il créer une véritable I.A (Intelligence Artificielle) ?
Alors, déjà, merci Tsunagari pour ta question qui est très intéressante,
elle regroupe beaucoup de choses en fait
parce qu'il y a pleins d'aspects, pour moi, à ta question.
Moi, je ne vais en traiter que deux :
le premier aspect, c'est peut être celui qui vient le plus directement,
c'est une prise de contrôle des humains par les robots
à la manière de Matrix, Hal 9000, ou I Robot par exemple,
avec Will Smith, qui est vraiment un film tout pourri.
Et le second aspect, qui m’intéresse plus, c'est celui qui va toucher
à l'automatisation des jobs dans notre société,
à courts et moyens termes pour la plupart des jobs et à longs termes pour les autres.
Du coup je vais traiter des deux parce que je suis un mec...Je suis un mec cool !
Déjà, pour le premier aspect, je me demandais dans quel cas,
ou comment, un robot pourrait vouloir nuire à l'homme.
En gros : qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour qu'on soit menacés ?
Parce que ce n'est pas parce que quelque chose est plus intelligent que nous,
qu'il va vouloir nous détruire ou se retourner contre nous.
Genre, Staline n'était pas plus intelligent que Gandhi.
Ce qu'il faudrait c'est que les robots aient une forme de volonté ou de soif de pouvoir,
ou bien qu'ils cherchent simplement à nous nuire, ou nous contrôler.
Alors bon, je vous avoue que, moi, avant de faire cette vidéo je pensais naïvement
qu'en fait tu connait ton intelligence avec tes règles.
Et puis BAM ! T'avais ton intelligence
En fait j'ai vu que l'intelligence pouvait se coder elle-même,
donc, non seulement, apprendre mais même genre se recoder
et que, par accident ou par un virus qu'elle générerait,
elle pourrait changer un type de code fondamental.
Mais bon c'est très peu probable parce que, dans ce cas, elle peut entrer surement son système en fait.
Et, quand je parle de lois fondamentales, je pense au lois d'Asimov.
Je ne rentre pas dans le détail mais en gros c'est :
Donc je t'avoue que ça me fait grave flipper.
Mais les spécialistes à qui j'en ai parlé m'ont dit que eux ils s'en ont absolument pas peur.
Pour eux, si jamais il y a un problème, ce n'est pas par la faute spontanée de l'intelligence artificielle,
mais ça va être à cause d'un développeur mal intentionné par exemple.
Donc, en vrai, est ce qu'il faut créer une véritable IA ?
Alors je ne sais pas trop ce que tu appelle ''véritable IA'',  mais si tu insinue
une intelligence qui serait plus intelligente que nous et qui aurait conscience d'elle même,
oui je dirais. Déjà parce qu'elle ne pense pas comme nous humains,
elle n'a pas cette chose qui nous pousse à vouloir toujours plus.
Puisque, pour moi, ce truc là viens de la conscience, de notre mentalité et de nos sentiments.
Et enfin, même si ça ne vient pas de là, en pensant que les robots ont les mêmes aspirations que nous
on l'anthropomorphise et on est dans l'erreur.
Ensuite, un robot qui s'auto-améliore de manière récursive, et donc qui peut changer son code,
ne sera jamais commercialisé.
Il sera commercialisé une fois que son code sera figé. Et pourra, parla suite recevoir des updates par exemple.
Ou bien si l'on est sur qu'il est inoffensif.
Donc voilà, si un jour tu as un robot qui veut te tuer il y a de grandes chances qu'il soit pleins de bugs,
ou qu'il soit dans une simulation, ou dans un laboratoire, ou encore que ce soit une arme terroriste.
Et dans ce cas il n'y a pas plus de raison d'avoir peur de l'intelligence artificielle que du nucléaire.
Et en plus, en approfondissant nos connaissances sur l'intelligence artificielle,
on va réussir à mieux la comprendre, mieux la faire fonctionner, mieux l'utiliser, et cetera.
Mais voilà, c'est une réaction relativement normale pour l'homme d'en avoir peur
ben parce que voilà, on a toujours peur des nouvelles technologies
Ensuite, est ce que l'intelligence artificielle peut causer une menace pour la société
par rapport à l'automatisation des emplois.
Alors, il y a CGP Grey, une superbe chaîne Youtube, qui a sorti une vidéo il y a quelques mois
que j'ai relayé sur tweeter, c'est pour ça qu'il faut me suivre sur tweeter d'ailleurs,
bref une vidéo qui parlait de cette automatisation des jobs par les robots.
Et il faut savoir qu'il y a environ 47% des jobs au USA qui sont potentiellement automatisables d'ici 10 à 20 ans
♪♫ Ambiance chômage ♫♪
Alors, la discussion elle est pas récente et elle est récurrente,
La question elle avait été de nouveau soulevé par un tweet d'Elon Musk.
Si vous le connaissez pas, c'est juste le fondateur de Paypal, de Tesla Motors et Space X
Donc c'est clairement une grosse brutasse.
C'est quelqu'un avec ce que j'appelle une vision et sa vision il nous l'a partagé avec ce Tweet.
" Je vous conseille de lire Super-intelligence de Bostrom. Il faut qu'on soit très vigilants avec l'Intelligence artificielle. C'est potentiellement plus dangereux que les bombes nucléaires."
Et il enchaîne avec :
"J’espère que nous ne sommes pas juste le chargeur de démarrage biologique d'une super-intelligence digitale. Malheureusement, c'est de plus en plus probable."
OK...
Alors effectivement beaucoup de jobs peuvent être automatisés.
Hein, vraiment beaucoup, du chauffeur de taxi avec la Google Car,
en passant par les médecins,
et même jusqu'aux jobs créatifs, genre il y a des robots qui font de la musique.
Nan nan, pas eux.
Oui voila comme Melomics, par exemple, qui compose ça :
Alors à ceux qui disent qu'on voudra jamais écouter de la musique faite par des robots.
Ba je sais pas trop, allez au Japon.
Ils font des concerts de Hatsune Miku, par exemple, dont la voix est synthétisée,
et qui est juste un hologramme géant.
Même cette vidéo pourrait être faite par un robot.
Seulement la position de la vidéo de CGP Grey qui tend à dire que nos jobs seront un jour ou l'autre tous volé par des robots
est long d'être celle partagés par tout le monde.
En fait ce n'est partagé que par 48% des experts selon une étude faite sur près de 2000 d'entre eux.
Les 52 autre % pensent que oui, ils nous prendront nos jobs mais c'est juste une migration,
nous les humains, on aura de meilleurs jobs qu'avant.
C'est notamment le point de vu de Vint Cerf, c'est un des créateur d'internet :
En gros ce qu'il dit c'est que ces robots faut les concevoir, faut les programmer et il y a tout un monde de service autour.
Bon, il m'a un peu rassuré. Un peu hein.
Parce que dans le cas où c'est les optimistes qui ont raison on va quand même faire une sacré transition au niveau job et en quelque années seulement
or rien n'est prêt.
C'est un peu comme si on était entrain d'inviter tout le monde à une grosse grosse soirée
Mais on ne sait pas encore où on va la faire, où est-ce qu'on va acheter l'alcool, qui sera le DJ… Bref, ça sent le roussi.
Même si à priori, les transition se font très rapidement.
Parce que comme mon père me la dit lorsque je lui est parlé de cette vidéo :
"Mon fils, tu sous-estimes entreprenariat et capitalisme."
Et c'est vrai que je pense qu'il a raison.
Dans le cas ou les pessimistes ont raison,
À quoi servent les gens dans une société qui n'a pas besoin d'eux ?
pas besoin de leur travail ?
Comment sont-ils censé gagner des sous ?
Imaginer un chômage à 50%.
C'est pour ça qu'en fait si les pessimiste on raison, ça n'arrivera jamais.
pourquoi ? et bien parce qu'on est dans un système capitaliste
et que le capitaliste à besoin d'une chose essentiel, les consommateurs.
Donc des gens qui gagnent de l'argent et qui pleuvent en dépenser.
Le capitalisme ne se laissera pas couler tout seul
et les entreprises, si jamais elles commencent une forte automatisation,
vont se rendre compte que rapidement plus personne ne peut acheter leurs produits.
Ça me rappelle un peu ce qu'il c'est passé avec les bas de nylon.
On en a fait de super résistant, tellement que les femmes n'en achetaient qu'une seule paire
et donc ça consommait plus ou pas assez.
Donc ils ont affaibli la fibre exprès pour que les bas soit moins résistant.
Le capitalisme s'arrange toujours pour retomber sur ses pattes.
Et oui je suis un optimiste.
Donc voilà, on peut imaginer d'autres menaces, par exemple comme des menaces liées aux resources.
Mais je vais m'arrêter la pour l'instant,
même si je pense que je vais vous reparler de l'Intelligence artificiel dans mon long périple
de création de vidéos ludiques sur internet.
Les menace qu'on a vu ne sont pas des menace à mon sens, on n'a pas à s'inquiété de cette IA.
Et si un jour il y a un risque pour l'humanité,
il viendra de l'humain. Voilà.
Un gros merci à David et Goulvain.
Le premier qui fait une thèse sur l'intelligence artificielle en Irlande, il a aussi un enchaîne youtube que je vous mets là.
Et le second a un doctorat en Intelligence artificielle
et il a aussi une boite qui fait de la robotique et de l'automatisation qui s'appelle CyberEspar.
Leur tweeters sont dans la description, le mien aussi
et pour le prochaine épisode je ne traiterai pas pas une seule question mais plusieurs.
Comme ça vous aurez plus de chance de voir votre question sélectionnée.
Voilà, j'espère que ça vous aura plus et on se revoit pour un prochain coup de phil'
et un prochain Ask.
Peace !
Qui sera un live du coup.
Se sera un live mais se sera annoncé sur ma page Facebook.
Donc, allez sur ma page Facebook.